this video premiered during teching
one-on-ones charity livestream to
benefit important medical research to
fight leukemia I will link the stream in
the description if you'd like to support
this worthy cause
and please show taking some love for all
the hard work he did to make this happen
[Music]
what is up everybody at Santa Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video I
will be talking about my favorite anime
character of all time
someone who I see not only as a cool
fictional character but also as an
inspiration to me in my everyday life I
mean even my youtube name which is Anna
Mac with a k' was derived simply by
taking the name of my favorite anime
character kameena and reversing the
letters yeah think about it I'll give
you a minute anyway
everyone who knows me knows how much I
love kameena and Gurren Lagann and how
the philosophy behind the character
kameena the idea of always thinking
outside the box and making the
impossible possible is the philosophy by
which I strive to live my life but with
that said I have to admit that I often
come across people who don't have the
same appreciation for communist
character and believe it or not
ScrewAttack actually placed kameena at
number 7 on their list of the top 10
dumbest anime characters and yes I know
that ScrewAttack is not any sort of
reliable authority on anime but that
video still has over six thousand likes
and less than five hundred dislikes
I mean dear God I cannot begin to tell
you how much this works me and the only
real explanation is that kameena has to
be one of the most misunderstood
characters in anime my good friend NOx
talk who actually gave me the idea for
making this video because he knows how
much it bugs me when someone criticizes
Gurren Lagann and coming out without
bothering to consider the incredibly
important philosophical aspects of the
series in fact NOx likes to call me the
triggered philosopher because I actually
spent years studying political science
and philosophy and even though Gurren
Lagann can be enjoyed as just a fun
action shown and in a post-apocalyptic
setting with a unique animation style
what I love the most about this series
is the inspirational philosophical
message that can be found just below the
surface and I sincerely hope that if you
happen to be skeptical about Gurren
Lagann then in this video I will be able
to show you what this anime and the
character of kameena look like through
my eyes and I hope I can give you an
idea of why kameena remains my absolute
favorite fictional character
Gurren Lagann remains my absolute
favorite anime thank you in advance for
your time and consideration and now
let's dive into it in the very first
episode of Gurren Lagann our two
protagonists Simone and kameena are in a
village that is literally in an
underground cave the village experiences
frequent earthquakes which caused
widespread structural damage and
Simone's parents were killed and one
such earthquake when he was younger
Simone is a digger who digs in order to
expand the village on the ground and
also in order to find hidden treasures
kameena is his best friend and is a few
years older but the two of them are so
close that kameena considers Simone to
be his brother in spirit kameena is a
rebellious young man who leads the other
youth of the village to try to climb up
to the surface and leave the cave
meanwhile the village chief and many
others don't even believe that there is
a surface at all they've never seen it
the cave is all they know and when
kameena tells them that on the surface
there is no ceiling so they won't have
to worry so much about earthquakes he is
called a liar and a troublemaker to me
this is one of the best setups for an
anime ever because what we have here is
literally Plato's allegory of the cave
in anime form if you're not familiar
with Plato's allegory of the cave I will
explain it briefly
Plato was an ancient Greek philosopher
whose teacher Socrates was put to death
by the government of Athens for
allegedly corrupting the youth by
teaching them about views and
philosophies that were contrary to the
accepted beliefs of their society just
like kameena Socrates wanted the youth
to look beyond the conventional wisdom
established by society and for this he
was called a liar and a troublemaker in
his famous book of the Republic Plato
wants to explain how philosophers people
who think outside the box and question
conventional wisdom differ from other
people in order to do this Plato gives
us an allegory in which a group of
people have been chained to the wall of
a cave their entire lives and they are
chained in such a way that they are
always facing the same blank wall there
is a fire burning behind them that they
can't see and the light that the fire
creates projects shadows on the wall the
shadows are all that these people know
it is their entire world their reality
this is all they've ever known
so they accept it as the only reality
because they just don't know any better
the philosopher is like a prisoner who
manages to free himself from the chains
and is able to stand up and see what's
really happening he comes to understand
that the shadows on the wall are not
reality just illusions projections and
eventually he is able to climb up and
leave the cave to see what the surface
really looks like the trees the sky the
Sun and so on the philosopher realizes
that everything that he has been seeing
inside the cave up to this point was
just a pale reflection of the real truth
a tiny fraction of a much greater
reality the philosopher then walks back
into the cave and tries to tell the
people inside the cave who are still
tied up in the same place that they are
just watching shadows on the wall not
the real world but the people who were
stuck in the cave don't believe him
because he is challenging everything
they think they know in fact they call
him a liar and they want to kill him
just like the citizens of Athens killed
Socrates because they don't want their
worldview to be challenged they don't
want to believe that there is a surface
at all a world beyond the cave because
that would mean that everything they've
ever believed for their entire lives has
been a lie in general people want to be
comfortable inside the perceived reality
that they have constructed for
themselves they want a safe space inside
the cave people don't want their entire
reality to be challenged they don't want
to question all of their pre-existing
values and beliefs it is so much easier
to ignore uncomfortable questions and
dismiss criticism than it is to
second-guess everything we know but that
is exactly what the philosopher does he
questions critiques and pushes the
boundaries of our comfort zone and here
is the important point
kameena is plato's philosopher kameena
is a visionary who knows that there is a
surface a world beyond the cave the
others don't believe him they are
trapped in their own preconceived
notions until a giant Mecca falls
through the ceiling of the cave
revealing the surface when this finally
happens communi is ready and he inspires
him own to fight back against the giant
Mecca using a small mecca that Simone
found by accident during one of his digs
together with Yoko a girl from the
surface was fighting the giant Mecca as
well they defeat the mecca and leave the
village for the surface the surface is
full of these giant Mecca known as
gunman and at first Simone wants to
return to the village to the cave
because he is scared of this new
dangerous world but kameena refuses to
go back and he forces a Mon to stand and
fight against all odds he forces Simone
to reject common-sense and make the
impossible possible
kameena never retreats never yields
never looks back
and together they discovered that the
giant mecha are piloted by beast men
animalistic creatures with human-like
intelligence and there are also other
people on the surface fighting against
these beast men when they defeat one of
these mecca's kameena decides to hijack
it and pilot it for himself
something that never even occurred to
the humans on the surface but kameena is
the visionary the philosopher he breaks
through the paradigm he keeps moving
forward seeing what the others cannot
see and this is what inspires the other
humans on the surface to follow his
example to hijack other gunmen and to
form a human resistance force against
the beast men in order to emphasize
again the importance of all of this and
of Plato's allegory of the cave in
episode 5 Simone kameena and the others
who now follow them on their quest to
defeat the beast men stumble into
another underground village by accident
in this village called a die the gunmen
mecha are worshipped like gods
and when kameena tells them that the
gunmen are not gods but merely mecca's
piloted by beast men they get upset
because he is challenging their
long-held beliefs again coming up lays
the role of the philosopher he searches
for the truth and for justice and he
cannot understand that there are people
out there who are willing to live a lie
just because it's easier than accepting
the truth
commie name and says that he would
rather die than live this way he always
looks outside the box outside the cave
he is a leader and a visionary and his
behavior can appear completely
irrational to others because he rushes
into headfirst into battles and believes
that his manly spirit and willpower is
all he needs to destroy any enemy
kameena is an idealist someone who
always looks forward and yearns for
truth and justice someone who is never
satisfied with the status quo some have
said that communist just crazy and
reckless or dumb to use screwattack's
terminology fricking ScrewAttack but to
be fair the list of people who think
this about kameena includes
not only some viewers of the anime but
also many of the characters in the
actual show however rather than being
crazy or dumb kameena is exactly the
type of person humanity needs in that
moment in time in the horribly bleak and
dangerous situation that humans find
themselves in within the caves and on
the surface common sense is not enough
being reasonable and practical is not
enough if we think about the situation
in terms of common sense it's clear that
the beastmen are way more powerful at
the beginning of the series and a
practical person in that moment in time
will conclude that the beastmen will
inevitably win and that resistance is
therefore futile I mean the beastmen
have superior numbers superior weaponry
superior Intel superior everything but
kameena takes it upon himself to be the
symbol and the pillar of hope for others
he refuses to accept the so-called
inevitable he thinks outside the box and
by seeing his example and following it
the other humans on the surface become
hopeful and confident that they can
actually make a difference and fight
back against the enemy kameena is a true
visionary leader exactly the type of
leader humanity needs at that point
which is why the others follow him even
though he might seem crazy to some we
have to remember that geniuses often do
for example Nikola Tesla was called
crazy when in the late 1800s he
advocated for alternating currents as
superior to the more established direct
current that was being pushed by Thomas
Edison in the end alternating current
one and we all use it to power our homes
today Steve Jobs was also called crazy
for thinking that everyone will one day
own a personal computer in their homes
way back when computers were the size of
an entire room and I think we all know
how that turned out and just like these
visionaries from our own world
kameena was called crazy from wanting to
leave the cave and from wanting to fight
against seemingly impossible odds and
yet he inspired and mobilized so many
others and because of him they were able
to do the impossible
communist brilliant leadership and
philosophy creates a chain reaction and
no matter what happens to him in the end
his ideas continued to live on forever
so it should go without saying that
kameena is not a dumb character on the
contrary he is a visionary character
kameena inspires us to think beyond what
society says as possible and
see what others can't see because they
refuse to look in this completely new
direction he inspires us to leave the
cave and to achieve the impossible or at
least what others think is impossible
because they don't know any better all
they know are shadows on the wall of the
cave but just because they believe that
something is impossible doesn't mean
that you have to accept it just because
they tell you that your hopes and dreams
are unrealistic doesn't mean that they
actually are this is what coming that
teaches us and I do my very best to make
communist philosophy and outlook on life
my personal philosophy and my outlook on
life even the fact that I made this
video and that I'm speaking to you right
now is due in part to this philosophy
that I learned from kameena and Gurren
Lagann I first saw Gurren Lagann back in
2010 long before I ever considered doing
YouTube in the years that followed I
went through grad school spent many
years studying political science and
philosophy until I finally earned a PhD
in political philosophy however after
putting all of that hard work into
attaining the highest possible level of
formal education I quickly realized that
society didn't actually care about my
degree I applied to over a hundred
academic jobs and administrative jobs
over the course of a year and I didn't
receive a single call back for an
interview it was a major low point in my
life because I felt that I wasted years
of my life working hard to achieve
something that in the end wasn't worth
anything to anyone if I didn't have
communist idealistic and uplifting
philosophy if I didn't have the capacity
to think outside the box and defy
conventional wisdom I would probably
still be desperately searching for some
academic job that may never come but
thanks to the fact that my brother and I
loved anime including Gurren Lagann we
decided to try doing something
completely out of left field we decided
to try making anime videos on YouTube
something that doesn't require any
academic degree and something that our
parents and other family members thought
was a complete waste of time with so
many people uploading videos to YouTube
every single day what were the chances
that our videos would gain traction and
that we would ever be able to make a
living by talking about Japanese
cartoons on the Internet and yet here we
are my brother goes in and I were able
to do exactly that
with our channel anime uproar and to be
honest the academic degrees that we both
have do actually come in handy because
in university we learned to do research
right argumentative
papers explained our points effectively
etc and all of these qualities are
extremely useful for the types of
YouTube videos that we make but if I
didn't understand the character of
kameena and the true message of Gurren
Lagann who knows maybe I wouldn't have
had the courage to throw a logic to the
curb and try something completely
different maybe I would still be stuck
inside the cave looking for the kind of
conventional jobs that were directly
related to my degree something that my
parents and others around me would
consider the logical thing to do but
thanks to coming out whenever someone
tells me and my brother that our goals
and dreams are impossible that we should
be more realistic that we should just
stick to what we know I know exactly
what to tell them in return
if you guys enjoyed this video be sure
to leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime or don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
feel free to hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar if you don't
want to talk about coming out or Gurren
Lagann I am always down for that just a
quick note an earlier draft of the
script for this video was published as
part of a longer video I made over a
year ago about five anime that I found
inspiring including who and Lagann but I
wasn't happy with the sound quality and
other aspects of that video so I'm
extremely grateful to NOx for
encouraging me to rework this concept
into a video of its own as always thank
you guys so much for watching it means a
lot to me and until next time see us
bass cowboys
[Music]
you